In the example we've shown here, we have three different DSL routers. The y axis
shows the round trip time, or the latency
to a nearby server in milliseconds, and is
again shown in a long scale. We started an upload at the time 30 seconds shown
on the plot. Now you can see that
different modems experience a huge increase in latency,
when we start this upload. Some of them experience a latency of as much as
one second up from a typical latency of
about ten miliseconds. One particular modem saw a
round trip latency of as high as ten
seconds during uploads. Now to remind you what's
going on here, is that the modem itself has a buffer. Your ISP may be upstream
of that buffer, and your access link may
be draining that buffer at a certain rate. TCP
senders in your home will send until they
see lost packets, but if the buffer's large, the
senders won't actually see those lost packets until
this buffer has already filled up. The senders continue
to send at increasingly faster rates until they
see a loss. As a result, packets that are
arriving at this buffer see increasing delays,
and senders continue to send at faster rates,
because without packet loss they don't have
a signal to slow down. There's several solutions
to the buffer bloat problem. One is
obviously to use smaller buffers, but given that
we have a lot of deployed infrastructure,
simply reducing the buffer size in deployed routers,
modems, switches, home Wi-Fi devices and so forth
is a tall order. The other thing that
we can do, is to use the traffic
shaping methods that we have learned about. Consider that
the buffer drains at a particular rate, which, in this case, is the rate of the
uplink to the ISP. If we shape traffic
such that traffic coming into the access link never
exceeds the uplink that the ISP has
provided us, then the buffer will never fill.
Thus, by shaping traffic at the home router
such that the rate that traffic is sent
to the ISP, never exceeds the rate of the uplink, the modem buffer will never
actually fill up. This type of shaping can
be done on many open WRT capable routers,
including the Bismark routers that we've developed here at Georgia Tech.